Voiceover: In Couple A, right over here,
I have 2 individuals
who make $100,000 each
in taxable income.
The first thing I want to think about
is how much they would pay
if they were taxed as individuals.
Let's look at the individual
tax brackets here,
and get our calculator to
figure out what that would be.
For each of them, the first
8,925 of taxable income
is going to be taxed at 10%,
and if we round, that's $893.
$893.
Then the next increment,
from 8,925 to 36,250,
is going to be taxed at 15%.
I pre-calculated what that is.
That's $4,099, rounding a bit.
4,099.
Then the increment up to $87,850
is going to be taxed at 25%,
and that gets us $12,900.
Then the increment above 87,850,
this is essentially the
bracket they fall into,
because they make less than $183,250,
that's going to be taxed at 28%.
It's going to be + .28 x the increment
above 87,850, so we have
100,000 of taxable income.
Do I have the right number of zeros?
Let me see; 1 ...
That's 100; that's 10,000 right now.
That is 100,000; did I do that?
Yeah, 100,000 - 87,850.
87,850, gets us to $21,294.
This is what they would
each pay as individuals,
but we're going to look
at them as a couple,
so as a couple, both of them combined,
if we multiply by 2, both
of them are combined,
if they were taxed as individuals,
or if they had never got married,
and, I don't know, they
just lived together,
what their combined taxes
would be, is $42,588.
So $42,588, combined,
if they're not married.
Now let's think about
how much they would pay
as a married couple,
where they have $200,000
of combined taxable income.
Now we would look at the filing
jointly married brackets,
and even if you're married
and you file as individuals,
your brackets are essentially going to be
half of these brackets right over here,
so it comes out economically equivalent,
or it comes out economically equivalent
if you make the same incomes.
We're going to talk about
that a little bit more.
Let's look at this married,
filing jointly, scenario for Couple A.
Let's get the calculator back out.
Now we'll look at the married brackets.
So the first 17,850 is
going to be taxed at 10%.
You might already notice that,
at least these first few brackets
are exactly twice the numbers
as these brackets right over here,
and the general idea is
you now have 2 people,
so they can essentially
have twice the income
before they fall into another bracket.
But that keeps on going
until you get to this
point right over here,
and that's actually the
whole point of this video;
to explore whether this results in
married couples paying
larger or smaller taxes.
Let's think about how
much this couple's paying.
The first 17,850, 10%; that's $1,785.
Then the increment up to 72,500
is going to be taxed at 15%.
Pre-calculated, that is
$8,188, right over there.
Then the increment up to 146,400
is going to be taxed at 25%.
Pre-calculated that as $18,475.
Oh, I don't want to have that.
Let me delete one of these plus signs.
Then, finally, finally,
we fall into this bracket right over here.
It's going to be taxed at 20%.
The increment above 146,400,
the increment above that
is going to be taxed at 28%,
so it's 28% x 200,000.
200, 1, 2, 3, - 146,400,
and we get combined taxes of 43,456.
43,456.
Now, what immediately jumps out at you?
Well, first, these are
not the same number.
In particular, when they're married,
they pay higher taxes,
so this couple, that they
have fairly high income,
and they both make the same amount,
they would have actually paid fewer taxes
if they never got married,
and if they just filed as individuals.
Now, when they're married,
they're paying more taxes,
and the main idea is, they
fall into this bracket,
and this bracket came faster
than twice the rate at
which this bracket came,
when they were just filing individually,
and so they fell into
the 28% bracket faster,
so they had to pay 28% on
more of their combined income;
they ended up having a bigger tax bill.
When people talk about
the marriage penalty,
this is what they're talking about.
These people are essentially paying a tax
because they got married.
This is the marriage penalty.
Now, let's explore if there's
always a marriage penalty.
If there's always a case,
that if by getting married,
you're going to pay more by income taxes.
Here we have Couple B, and
they have less equal income.
They still have a combined
income of $200,000,
so if you look at the
married filing jointly,
they're still going to pay 43,456
when they file jointly,
but let's see how much they would pay
if they were individuals;
if they never got married,
and we combine how much
they would have had to pay.
Let's get the calculator back out.
First we're going to think about
the first member of the couple,
who makes 180,000 in taxable income.
They're going to pay 10%
on the first 8,925, so that's 893,
and then we can add that to 4,099;
we've done this already.
4,099.
To that we could add 12,900.
12,900.
And then, to that,
we're going to add 28% of
the increment above ...
so he makes or she makes 180,000.
180, 1, 2, 3, - 87,850.
87,850.
So that's the increment above 87,850,
and we get this spouse,
this member of the couple,
is going to pay 43,694.
Now, to that we're going to have to add
the amount that the other
member that might pay.
He is going to pay 893 on the first 8,925,
so it's going to be 893 plus the 15%
of the increment above 8,925.
So, + .15 x 20,000; 1, 2, 3, - 8,925,
gets us to, this member of the couple
is going to pay, let's
see, 2,554 in taxes.
If we add it to the other
member of the couple,
so we add that answer + 43,694,
that's what the larger earner
is going to have to pay in taxes,
we get 46,248; we'll just round to that.
46,248.
So here, all of a
sudden, we see a scenario
where the opposite thing;
the higher value is if
they don't get married.
In this situation, they
actually got a marriage benefit.
They got a marriage benefit.
Now, why did this happen?
The thing that might
have jumped out to you,
both of these people had high incomes,
and they had very equal incomes,
while both of these people,
their combined income was the same,
but there was less equal,
and so essentially what happened here,
this person filed by themselves;
on the individual tax bracket,
they go up the brackets very,
very, very, very quickly,
and then this person,
well, they're not paying much in taxes,
but this person is paying the bulk of it.
By becoming a couple, by getting married,
as a combined entity,
and pretty much this is
the main beneficiary,
that 180,000 in taxable income,
that's most of the 200,000,
they're able to move up the
tax brackets a lot slower,
so they're getting taxed at 28%
on a much smaller
fraction of their income.
They're getting taxed at 25%
on a much smaller
fraction of their income.
They're getting taxed at 10%
on a larger fraction of the income
than when, especially this
individual right over here,
filed as an individual.
In general, if you have a couple
with very high taxable income,
and they both make roughly equal,
they both have very high
taxable incomes as individuals,
they are likely to see a marriage penalty,
like we saw in scenario 1.
If you have a couple where their salaries
are very unequal, even if
their combined salaries
are quite high, you actually
might get a marriage benefit,
because they move through
the tax brackets faster.
Now let's think about Couple C,
and I'll let you think
about it a little bit.
You have equal taxable incomes here,
so it's like Couple A,
but their total taxable income isn't high.
In fact, if you look at
the married filing jointly,
they fall under this tax
bracket right over here.
And, notice, up to this point,
all the tax brackets are exactly double
the individual tax bracket,
so it goes exactly twice as slow.
I guess you could think about it as
a fraction of income,
when you have 2 people making the same,
you're having the same fraction taxed
at 20% or at 15% or at 25%.
I encourage you to do the math here.
It's just good practice,
but what you're going to see,
is these people are going
to pay the same taxes.
This is going to be the same
whether or not they are
married or not married,
because they're not making
enough combined income
to get the penalty, where the brackets
start accelerating a little bit faster.
Anyway, hopefully that
clarifies things a little bit.